مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
الانسانيه الخاصه وفيها نناقش معاناه
الاطفال حديثي الولاده في قطاع غزه اذ
قالت اليونيسيف ان 20 الف طفل ولدوا في
قطاع غزه خلال ايام الحرب ال5 منذ السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي وقد وصفت المنظمه اوضاع
هؤلاء الاطفال بالقول انهم يولدون في
الجحيم وانه من المحتمل ان يموت العديد
منهم بس بظروف القاسيه في القطاع لمناقشه
هذه القضيه ستكون معنا من واشنطن
الكساندرا سايح رئيسه قسم السياسات
الانسانيه بمنظمه انقذوا الاطفال في
التفاصيل اذا قالت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله اليونيسيف ان نحو 20 الف طفل
ولدوا في قطاع غزه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي بمعدل مولود جديد كل عشر دقائق
ولدوا في جحيم الح حرب بحسب وصفها وقالت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في تقريرها اليومي
عن اثار العدوان المتواصل على قطاع غزه ان
هناك
52000 امراه حامل وحوالي
183 ولاده يوميا اضافه الى
5500 طفل ولدوا في الشهر الماضي فقط من
واشنطن اذا معنا الكساندرا سايح رئيسه قسم
السياسات الانسانيه بمنظمه انقذوا الاطفال
سيده الكساندرا كيف تراقبون هذا الوضع
وماذا تفعلون عندما تقول اليونيسيف انما
يجري هي ولادات في
الجحيم شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه اولا الوضع
بالنسبه ل للنساء الحوامل والاطفال حديثي
الولاده في غزه هو وضع مرعب فعلا كل يوم
اكثر من 180 رضيعا يولدون في ظروف صعبه
للغايه حيث لا تتوفر لهم رعايه طبيه او
تغذيه مناسبه وفي كثير من الحالات ليس
لديهم مكان يلجؤون اليه يؤويهم اذا التحدي
الذي يواجه النساء الحوامل هي كثيره اولها
لا توجد هناك مستشفيات تعمل بشكل كامل في
قطاع غزه ولا واحده حتى من ال 36 مستشفى
التي كانت تعمل قبل السابع من اكتوبر
تستطيع ان تؤدي عملها الان وما بقي منها
غمرته الاحداث ولم تعد لديهم لا معدات ولا
مستلزمات وهناك كثير من الاصابات الصعبه
والمعاني من الصدمات
الذين يكتظ في هذه
المستشفيات اسرائيل تعتمد التجويع كسلاح
في الحرب لذلك الامهات يعانين من عدم
القدره على ارضاع اطفالهم او اطعامهم
الوضع اذا ماساوي بالنسبه للنساء والامهات
والاطفال هؤلاء ما المطلوب حاليا و باي
سرعه يجب التدخل من اجل انقاذ
الوضع
نحن طالبنا وما زلنا نطالب بوقف لاطلاق
النار لانه الامر الوحيد الذي سيبقي على
سكان غزه احياء وتصل اليهم المساعدات
بالمستوى المطلوب من الامور العاجله ان
المنظمات الاغاثه تحتاج الى القدره على
الوصول الى شمال غزه الوضع سيء في كل مكان
لكن في شمال غزه هو اكثر تفاقما حتى الامم
المتحده تشكو من عدم القدره على ايصال
المساعدات الاوضاع في المستشفيات صعبه لا
توجد مستشفيات قادره على اداء عملها بشكل
كامل يفتقرون الى الدقيق والطحين والبيض
والحليب الوضع صعب للغايه نحن نحتاج الى
المنظمات الانسانيه ان تكون قادره على
ايصال المواد الاغاثه ونحتاج الى وقف
لاطلاق النار فورا لانه الامر الوحيد الذي
سيسمح بوصول الاغاثه الى الاطفال والنساء
سيدي الكساندرا وفي هذه الظروف التي
تصفينها لنا نحن نتحدث عن
183 ولاده يوميا ما فرص الحياه لدى هؤلاء
الاطفال
والنساء هذا سؤال صعب للغايه فنحن نعلم ان
الكثير من النساء
يعانين من حالات الاجهاض
وفقدان الحمل بسبب الضغط والتوتر
والافتقار الى ابسط المقومات
الصحيه في غزه ايضا كثير من الاطفال
يعانون من سوء التغذيه وكلما طال امد هذه
المعاناه من سوء التغذيه زادت فرصهم
بالموت من الموت من امراض عاديه مثل
الاسهاب
وغيرها عدم حصولهم على التغذيه يمنعه من
الحصول على المناعه الكافيه لمقاومه هذه
الامراض لهذا السبب نحن بحاجه لان نضمن ان
الاطفال والنساء الحوامل يجب ان يحصلوا
على الطعام الكافي والماء النظيف الكافي
وغيرها من المقومات وفي هذه الظروف لا سما
التجويع الذي يتعرض له سكان القطاع ما هي
الانعكاسات على المدى الطويل على حديثي
الولاده كلما طال امد الاطفال حديثي
الولاده والاطفال الصغار استمروا من دون
الحصول على طعام كاف كلما زادت الفرص في
ان يؤثر ذلك على نموهم الطبيعي وفرص نموهم
الطبيعي كلما زادت فتره معاناته من الجوع
فان
نموهم
واكتماله البدني والعقلي والادراكي
والقدرات البدنيه ستتاح عندما يكبرون
اشكرك من واشنطن الكساندرا سايح رئيسه قسم
السياسات الانسانيه بمنظمه انقذوا
الاطفال مشاهدينا ختام هذه النافذه
الانسانيه عوده الان الى الزملاء في غرفه
الاخبار لمتابعه هذه التغطيه الى اللقاء